on d'une évasion réalisé dans ces mêmes
conditions dans trois ans 1992 usines
renault de billancourt ne fera plus
partie de l'actualité sociale ou
économique mais de l'histoire
industrielle et sociale de notre pays en
effet c'est à cette date environ qu'elle
fermera définitivement ses portes
cette usine installée en grande partie
sur l'île seguin et en bord de seine a
été depuis 1929 date de son inauguration
le théâtre de grands événements à la
fois politiques économiques et syndicaux
qui ont marqué ce siècle en france fille
dégâts sont l'histoire de la régie
renault commence à boulogne billancourt
tout simplement parce que la famille
renault y possède une maison
l'atelier louis renault existe toujours
c'est la qu'amateur il construit de ses
mains sa première voiture ils en
fabriquent tous les éléments sauf le
moteur 1 de dion bouton de trois chevaux
il veut vendre le brevet de la boîte et
de la transmission son frère lui conseil
de fabrique et il devient industrielle
dès 1908 c'est le triangle du travail au
chronomètre le taylorisme on travaille
12 heures par jour sans repos
hebdomadaire les femmes travaillent la
nuit
renault c'est aussi la marne et ses
taxis en 1918 à billancourt on fabrique
les premiers chars d'assaut
chez renault on introduit le travail et
la chaîne les temps modernes pour les
industriels une longue période noire
pour les ouvriers ont construit sur
l'île seguin juste en face
en 1936 133 1000 ouvriers qui réclament
les congés payés les gardes mobiles
donnent l'assaut les syndicats et
notamment la cgt
avec 87% des voix refuse l'augmentation
du temps de travail
deux mille ouvriers seront licenciés
louis renault incarne pour les syndicats
l'industriel impitoyable l'ennemi de la
classe ouvrière les grèves des bouches
avec le front populaire sur les premiers
quinze jours de congés payés les
industriels craignent la ruine pourtant
250 voitures sortent chaque jour des
usines renault
la seconde guerre mondiale bloquent la
production les usines travaillent pour
l'occupant les alliés bombardent à haute
altitude les bâtiments seront détruits à
80% des civils seront tués dans les
quartiers environnants
on reproche à louis renault d'avoir
collaboré avec l'ennemi
il meurt en 1944 lusine sera nationalisé
par ordonnance du 16 janvier 1945 et les
actions confisquer la voiture la plus
populaire au sortir de la guerre sera la
fameuse quatre chevaux puis viendra la
dauphine et la 4l dans les années 60 ans
social billancourt donne toujours le là
quand renault tous et l'industrie
française tout entière qui sans même en
1968 grève dure accords de grenelle
jean paul s'appuie mort de pierre
overney à présent lusine n'est plus
performantes dit on allait dépasser ces
terrains devrait faire le bonheur des
promoteurs
c'est en 92 condé boulogne billancourt
le président la république monsieur